[Applauso]
agli inizi della mia carriera di
formatrice mi veniva chiesto
continuamente che rapporto avessi con la
mia famiglia con mia nonna con il mio
contesto di origine
la domanda era in genere maliziosa il
non detto
il sottotesto di quella domanda era che
l'accettazione da parte della famiglia
fosse qualcosa se non
indispensabile di molto importante
del resto perché chiederlo se non si
pensa che sia in qualche modo importante
la risposta che davo più frequentemente
era ed è che ho scelto di far porno per
far piangere mia nonna
e in genere l'interlocutore all
intervistatore davanti a questa risposta
restava pietrificato
quando dicevo nonna non si trattava solo
della nonna in senso letterale
la nonna è anche il simbolo delle radici
familiari
la nonna la nonna materna
rappresenta per la famiglia ciò che per
la specie umana e le pa mitocondriale la
femmina da qui discende tutta la specie
umana
la nonna
rappresenta la progenitrice la nonna
rappresenta dunque le origini
e sistema ragione profonda dietro il
fatto che la scelta di fare porno
suscita immediatamente la solita domanda
sulla famiglia sulla donna e sul
contesto di origine
la ragione profonda e che esiste un
conflitto fra radici e porno il
conflitto fra radici e porno è una
discriminazione
del conflitto fra radici e avanzamento
della modernità ma perché esiste un
conflitto fra radici e avanzamento della
modernità perché la modernità e
sradicate e tutto ciò che fa avanzare la
modernità in un certo senso uccide la
nonna
ora vi starete chiedendo che cosa io
intenda per modernità
ebbene la modernità è un certo modo di
rapportarsi con l'antichità con le
origini
detto molto semplicemente la modernità e
il passaggio da una visione del mondo
fondata sull'idea che gli antichi
fossero migliori più saggi e più
venerabili di noi ha una visione del
mondo fondata sull'idea che noi siamo
migliori più saggi e più venerabili
degli antichi
per usare le parole di giordano bruno
parole che inaugurano la modernità noi
siamo più vecchi e abbiamo più lunga età
che i nostri predecessori
vi invito a riflettere sulla portata di
questa rivoluzione copernicana
rivoluzione però che ancora oggi nel
mondo contemporaneo
non si è ancora del tutto attuata
infatti anche nel mondo moderno e
contemporaneo
resiste un certo modo
premoderno di guardare alle origini e
alle radici
che consiste nel mitizzarli
resiste il mito delle origini e delle
radici dato dall incapacità di
considerare in maniera analitica
anaffettiva algida la nostra storia il
nostro passato
i nostri genitori
la nostra terra
umberto eco molto correttamente
sostiene che la prima caratteristica del
lul fascismo ovvero della componente
fascista delle culture e delle mentalità
anche quelle che si sono date prima e
dopo il fascismo e il nazismo storici e
il culto della tradizione e delle radici
notate bene questa è la prima
caratteristica dell'urss fascismo
secondo euro e infatti anche nel mondo
contemporaneo
i principali
pensatori fascisti
venerano in qualche modo le origini come
ad esempio in alexander game l'ideologo
di putin
jogging è un pensatore pre moderno
che pensa che i popoli debbano restare
fedeli alla loro naturale e tradizionale
vocazione storica
potremmo dire che un pensatore radici
sta
ovviamente modernità non vuol dire
ignorare la storia vuol dire viceversa
guardare scientificamente alla storia
modernità vuol dire de incantare la
storia modernità vuol dire di incantare
le origini
ora possiamo rispondere alla domanda che
cosa c'entra il porno
il porno gay incanta il corpo e il sesto
gli anticoncezionali ci permettono da un
punto di vista pratico di slegare il
sesso dalla riproduzione dalla capacità
di dare origine a una vita
il porno completa l'opera
dal punto di vista culturale
il porno è dunque parte integrante del
processo di bee incantamento del passato
del corpo del sangue
dell'origine che si dà con la modernità
il porno non è dunque compatibile con il
e targi retaggi mater cali o patriarcali
che ancora resistono nel mondo
contemporaneo
il porno non è dunque compatibile con la
nonna e il porno è necessariamente
nemico del tradizionalismo e del
radicamento
nell'origine
ed è questa la principale differenza tra
pornografia ed erotismo
l'erotismo è compatibile con la
tradizione e con le radici la fotografia
no perché perché la pornografia dei
incanta il corpo e la sessualità la
pornografia trasforma la sessualità in
tecnologia e questo è incompatibile con
le concezioni tradizionali della
sessualità
dunque la mia scelta di fare porno non è
integrabile una visione del mondo che
ancora incorpora specialmente in materia
di sesso retaggi premoderni la cultura
contemporanea non è ancora abbastanza
moderna da accettare la forza sra di
kant e della pornografia
per questo motivo scegliendo di fare
porno ho scelto di fare la guerra al
mondo una guerra contro la nonna una
guerra contro le origini
[Applauso]